ما هو في رقم على وجه التحديد
هذا الرقم لا يمكن للجميع التوقف عن
ملاحظته هذه الأيام جيدًا على المستوى الوطني في
الوقت الحالي ، سعر الغاز أثناء
تصويرنا هذا هو أربعة دولارات و 30
سنتًا للجالون هنا في كاليفورنيا
حيث نصور هذا حتى  أعلى
أعلى سعر في البلاد الآن هو
خمسة دولارات وسبعين سنتًا ، لذا
فما يذهب في جالون من الغاز ، فلنقم
بتفصيله هنا في كاليفورنيا ،
ينشرون تفصيلًا لما يحدث في الواقع في
تكلفة جالون من الغاز
سوف يركزون على ذلك ويستخدمون خمسة
دولارات وتسعة عشر سنتًا للغالون من أجل
هذا ، لذا فهذه هي الأرقام التي سنستخدمها
أولاً في
الضرائب ، هناك الولاية المحلية
والفيدرالية وهناك تباين كبير في
ضرائب الولاية متوسط المكوس الوطني  تبلغ الضريبة
ما يزيد قليلاً عن 25 سنتًا للغالون ، بينما
أقلها هو ثمانية سنتات في ألاسكا ، ولكن
هنا في كاليفورنيا تبلغ 51 سنتًا في اليوم ،
تذهب هذه التكاليف إلى أشياء مثل
صيانة الطرق والبنية التحتية ،
ثم لديك ولاية محلية أخرى  الضرائب
والرسوم التي تضيف 13 سنتًا أخرى
، ثم هناك ضريبة الغاز الوطنية
التي تضيف 18.4 سنتًا للغالون ، وهذا
الرقم في الواقع لم يتغير
منذ عقود ، لذلك في جميع أنحاء منازل الولاية
ويدعو أفراد الحكومة الفيدرالية
إلى إعفاء ضريبي على الغاز للمساعدة في الحفاظ على
سعر الغاز أقل لكن البعض الآخر
يجادل بأنه لا يوجد
مصدر إيرادات مهم للغاية لخفضه ، ثم على 36
سنتًا لتسويق التوزيع
وأرباح محطات الوقود ،
تذهب الأموال نحو أشياء مثل مرافق أجور الإيجار
، تكلفة تأمين المضخة
الإعلان ثم ربح محطة الوقود
كل ذلك في 36 سنتا ثم هناك
تكلفة تكرير الغاز بإضافة
دولار واحد و 12 سنت للغالون
وتشمل تكرير الغاز
ونقله وأرباح
تلك الشركات ثم نصل إلى
أكبر قطعة.  من تكلفة
النفط الخام
الآن التي تضيف
2.87
لكل جالون الآن ، هذا هو
الجزء الأكبر والأكثر تذبذبًا مما يشكل
جالونًا من الغاز عند  عندما يرتفع سعر
الغاز ، يمكنك الاعتماد على تكلفة
النفط الخام التي ارتفعت للتو ، كما أن
كل هذه العوامل تدخل في ما
تدفعه في المضخة